imagines que tienen una máquina del
tiempo y quieren viajar a una época
arcaica prehistórica y en ese afán de
entender cómo el ser humano sobrevivió
utilizando tecnología muy primitiva te
lanzas al año 2003 lo primero que te
llama la atención son los celulares
vintage que usamos en aquel entonces
pero lo interesante se da cuando te
encuentras a ti misma a ti mismo en el
año 2003 y esa persona esa persona el
pasado tuyo del pasado te dice oye cómo
es la vida en nuestro futuro cómo es la
gente cómo nos comportamos como es la
tecnología imagínense platicarle nuestro
día a día una persona del año 2003 para
acceder a una idea mis estimados en 2003
no había whatsapp no había facebook no
había twitter no había instagram no vea
über no había verían vino había snap
chat no había spotify un avión netflix
streaming como lo como
colom o como lo conocemos el día de hoy
en este año mis estimados cuando la
gente decía asistente personal se
refería literalmente a un ser humano no
así y no a google oasis está en la
cortada nano alexa en aquella época la
gente se perdía no había google maps no
había ways y si traías contigo una
cámara en todo momento había tres
posibilidades número uno
profesional o eras periodista
profesional o eras japonés profesional
no había de otra
en aquel entonces cuando la gente decía
la nube se refería literalmente esas
cosas blancas que ahí arriba en el cielo
y agárrense en sus asientos mis
estimados en el 2003 no había self is ok
es el momento donde pierda la mitad de
la audiencia es impresionante como
sobrevivió sin selfish pero más
impresionante como un dispositivo
transformó a la humanidad entera en
menos de 10 años el celular los
transformó en algo a lo que yo le llamo
con cariño como smartphone y somos seres
que percibimos el mundo a través de
pantalla somos seres que leemos nos
informamos nos educamos trabajamos nos
comunicamos compramos vendemos a través
de pantallas y esta tecnología esta
comunicación nos ha dado mucho poder y
hoy quiero recalcar las cuatro
características que tenemos como
smartphone es en este poder del que
hablo número uno somos seres hiper
informados tenemos toda la información
en la palma de la mano no sabemos algo
sacamos el celular san google santa
wikipedia nos sacan de problemas número
dos somos seres hiper relacionados
tenemos cientos o miles de amigos y de
contactos en redes sociales ya sean
amigos relaciones de trabajo seguidores
etc
número 3 somos seres inmediatos ondemand
estamos acostumbrados a respuestas no
solo instantáneas sino personalizada la
tecnología los sistemas se adaptan a
nosotros y número 4 somos seres
omnipresentes tenemos la capacidad de
estar en muchos lugares a la vez y tener
una voz y llegar a todo el mundo la gran
pregunta y si estamos aprovechando estos
poderes esta capacidad que tenemos como
smartphone es para verdaderamente
transformar nuestras sociedades y la
vida de otras personas estamos generando
felicidad en la vida de otras personas y
entrando más en materia cómo le hacemos
para generar ideas para generar
proyectos que verdaderamente impacten en
la vida de otros seres humanos bueno
para llegar a esta definición les voy a
dar tres consejos básicos para generar
ideas de alto impacto en la vida de
otras personas número uno entiende la
nueva dimensión de nuestras necesidades
somos mart fon y somos seres hiper
tecnológicos pero detrás de cada de cada
uno de nosotros hay un ser primitivo no
debe practicar la historia de mi tátara
tátara tátara tatarabuelo subiera muy
sencilla el llegar a todos los días a
comer mi abuela le ponía un pedazo del
mamut crudo y el abuelo era feliz todos
los
comíamos crudo todo iba muy bien hasta
que un buen día llegó una vecina en la
cueva de lado la vecina pues quería
conquistar el corazón del abuelo mejor
dicho con conquistar el estómago del
abuelo lo invita a comer y le da de
comer mamut con la pequeña diferencia de
que usaba una cosa llamada sal en el
momento que el abuelo pruebe ese mamut
con sal bueno queda maravillado por ese
sabor y empezó a visitar un poco más
frecuentemente la vecina
beneficios adicionales por ahí no la
abuela no era tonta sabe que le están
pedaleando la bicicleta pero sabe que
los hombres el amor no se entra por el
estómago y entonces dice cómo le gana
esta señora y se le ocurre usar una cosa
llamada fuego y en el momento en que el
abuelo puede ser va ese mamut asado
bueno queda maravillado la vecina dejó
de ser importante para él pero la vecina
dice así pues y un piso usar vegetales y
especias y aquí empieza una guerra de
recetas entre las dos no la abuela
preparar el [ __ ] de una forma la vecina
lo preparada otra forma y el abuelo
maravillado mamut y todo lo demás de un
lado más múltiplo de más del otro él
estaba feliz hasta que las dos son las
mejores chefs de piedradura y la abuela
dice como le ganó esta tonta como le
ganó ya no sabía por dónde moverle y se
le ocurre decorar el plato y el abuelo
ay qué lindo se ve y la vecina dice
apoyo con el plato la mesa y aquí se
llama el rincón del mamut
la abuela dice apoyo decoro todo y
además los martes hay dos por uno en
mammoth y en todo lo demás para el que
quiera de la tribu no nomás para el
abuelo y la vecina se defiende y dice
así pues yo pongo mi restaurante más
rápido la abuela se defiende pone su
restaurant temático y la otra se empieza
a reportajes en revistas para hacer
públicos su restaurant mi abuela se
defiende hace un reality show hay un
baile en su restaurant la vecina se
acopla innova va de sacar los pedidos
por piedra net
mi abuela saca su blog y luego la vecina
se le ocurre una gran campaña donde a
los mamuts les ponían música clásica les
daban masajes y solo les daban de comer
bellotas para que fuera la carne más
deliciosa que vieras pero en tu vida en
la batalla mis estimados sigue y sigue
en los mundos físicos y en los mundos
virtuales vamos a entender esto vamos a
bajarlo a tierra que necesitamos y que
buscamos como seres humanos bueno en
primera instancia los seres humanos
queremos resolver necesidades básicas
queremos sobrevivir
el abuelo comía el mamut no le importaba
que estuviera crudo para sobrevivir
primer nivel de conexión con tu usuario
con tu cliente con la persona que
quieres ayudar cuando la abuela y la
vecina empiezan a decorar a preparar el
producto al gusto
segundo nivel de conexión con el cliente
cuando resuelves no solamente la
necesidad sino se la das con los sabores
con las características con los filtros
que hacen que le guste mucho más nivel
sensorial segundo nivel de conexión lo
interesante es qué pasa cuando la abuela
decore el plato qué necesidad estamos
resolviendo bueno la noticia interesante
mis estimados es que nuestro cerebro
también come y nuestro cerebro come
experiencias lo importante no es
solamente resolver la necesidad y cómo
las resuelven sino lo que pasa alrededor
de esa solución que tú le ofreces a tu
usuario a tu cliente voy a bajar esto un
poco más a tierra muchos de nosotros nos
gusta tomar café en las mañanas para
despertar si lo único que hay es café
soluble pues ni modo te lo tomas
resuelve la necesidad pero la mayoría de
nosotros que nos gusta tomar café para
despertar bueno
buscamos un café en grano porque nos da
el aroma el sabor las texturas eso que
nos gusta mucho más segundo nivel de
conexión lo interesante es que pasa con
un café como starbucks como delito
querido como la borra del café lo
importante no es solamente el café sino
lo que pasa la experiencia que vives en
lo que te conviertes
gracias a ese café eso es cuando logres
un tercer nivel de conexión y mayor
lealtad con tu usuario con tu cliente
cuando se engancha contigo y bueno
vivimos en un mundo de redes sociales y
eso nos ha llevado a un cuarto nivel de
conexión a un cuarto nivel de necesidad
que es el nivel social el nivel de
identidad donde la gente quiere ser
parte de algo mucho mayor que ellos en
el caso de los cafés el ejemplo es un
espresso un espresso ha servido ha
sabido crear una comunidad alrededor del
café y ha convertido al cliente en el
mejor embajador de marca ha cambiado la
experiencia y la comunidad alrededor del
café bueno ya entendimos las necesidades
como son la nueva dimensión de nuestras
necesidades segundo consejo para crear
proyectos de alto impacto entiende tu
propósito entiende que representas en la
vida del cliente y cómo conectar con él
les voy a dar aquí dos preguntas que si
quieren ustedes replantear su proceso
propósito pregúntense número uno de qué
se trata esto de qué se trata esto que
estamos haciendo y segunda pregunta que
logra o en qué se convierte
esa persona gracias a mí gracias a esta
solución que le estamos ofreciendo les
va a dar un ejemplo rápido normalmente
cuando nosotros describimos algo nuestro
negocio que hacemos nuestro proyecto
nuestra idea solemos quedarnos en los
dos primeros niveles de conexión si
alguien que no conoces ahora te dice oye
que sarah louisa es una tienda de ropa
tiene distinta calidad distintos
productos distinta variedad colores
precios etcétera pero eso no es el
secreto de éxito de sar si yo les
pregunto de qué se trata a sara sara se
trata de estar a la moda zara se trata
de verse espectacular hoy en la noche
una mujer que tiene una junta de trabajo
una cena tiene la tranquilidad de ir a
sara y saber que se va a ver muy bien en
esa en esa cena se trata de
autoconfianza y sara que hizo
democratizó el acceso a la moda
cualquiera puede tener moda mi esposa
dice hoy si la ropa de sala te da para
cinco puestas ellos como por qué estar
inventó este concepto llamado fast
fashion de las más vueltas más rápido a
la moda los hombres decimos mi traje
lleva 30 bodas y ahí sigue
adelante no lo entendemos pero bueno su
concepto conectó tremendamente con este
homo es martín es porque lo lleva a ser
algo mucho más grande la gran pregunta
mis estimados desde que se tratan otras
empresas
herb y andy se trata de recuerdos únicos
se trata de experiencias únicas y
recuerdos únicos teletón por ejemplo no
solamente se trata de cómo cambia la
vida de un niño con discapacidad de una
familia con un niño con discapacidad
sino se trata de hacernos una sociedad
más incluyente y de hacerlos parte de la
sociedad que es por ejemplo se trata de
sacarlos de nuestra zona de confort se
trata de ampliar nuestra visión ver
nuevas ideas pero nuevos puntos de vista
plantear nuevos proyectos de eso se
trata de que se trata tu proyecto de qué
se trata tu idea de que se trata tu
carrera es lo que quieres hacer para
otros bueno quieres plantearlo entiende
qué historia se escribe en la vida de
otras personas de otros seres humanos
gracias a esa solución ayúdalos a
visualizar en qué se pueden convertir no
te quedes en el primero y segundo nivel
de conexión no digas que haces y cómo
haces ayúdalos a visualizar cómo
convertirse en una mejor versión de sí
mismos conecta en el nivel de
experiencia y en el nivel de social en
el nivel social se parte de un
movimiento lo importante mis estimados
no es tu idea lo importante es el
resultado en la vida de esa persona lo
importante es qué pasa con ellos después
de ti yo uso dos siglas ate
dt antes de ti después de ti después de
tu solución después de tu idea cómo se
transforma su vida y eso me lleva al
tercer consejo para crear proyectos
ideas de alto impacto en la vida de
otros seres humanos y es que hay que ser
humano y activar nuestro gen de la
generosidad tenemos que activar hoy más
que nunca nuestro gen de la generosidad
porque porque así como el smartphone
transformó a la humanidad en unos
cuantos años lo que se viene con
internet of things lo que se viene con
inteligencia artificial va a transformar
tremendamente a la humanidad en menos de
diez años y hoy más que nunca tenemos
que enaltecer nuestras capas
humanas nuestra empatía nuestra
capacidad de compasión nuestra paciencia
cosas que las computadoras no van a
poder emular y se los dice un ingeniero
en sistemas computacionales no sé qué
demonios hago aquí dando pláticas en
público
pero bueno les quiero platicar una
historia que verdaderamente transformó
mi vida mi vida gracias a otro ser
humano hace poco más de tres años en un
día normal para mí yo estaba en casa y
me empecé a sentir un poco mareado
de repente empecé a sentir un dolor muy
intenso en el pecho y en el instante en
que mis brazos
empezaron or millar gracias adiós
conocía los síntomas de infarto y que
hay en cuenta de que estaba sufriendo un
infarto y ahí empezó una cadena de
milagros hermosas gracias a dios mi
esposa estaba en casa le grite y le dije
vámonos al hospital en este instante
gracias a dios vivimos a un kilómetro
del hospital llegamos a urgencias me
sacan un electrocardiograma y nos dicen
si está sufriendo un infarto muy grave
es una cuestión de vida o muerte la
última imagen que veo es a mi esposa
llorando totalmente desfigurada y yo
pensé es la última vez que la voy a ver
en ese momento me lleva en una sala de
hemodinamia y yo iba temblando no era un
temblor pequeño estaba sacudiendo en una
combinación de miedo de ansiedad de
agonía del dolor que yo sentía de cómo
se defendía mi cuerpo ante eso y de no
saber qué iba a pasar
estaban ahí en la sala de hemodinamia
tratando de intervenir me y el doctor me
decía por favor necesito que te
tranquilizas no te puedo intervenir
estaba tratando de hacerme un
cateterismo por el brazo y me decía
tranquilízate no te puedo intervenir yo
decía pues acuéstate no caí le cambiamos
de roles
pero yo me tranqui esta vez ya
tranquilízate te vas a morir tranquilo
respira pensaba en mis hijos pero no
había poder alguno que me ayudara a
tranquilizarme no lo lograba el temblor
la sacudida seguía las oleadas de dolor
eran lo más horrible que se pueden
imaginar ya llevábamos un rato con esto
muy largo tiempo y llegó un punto en que
yo digo adiós tal vez yo me estoy
aferrando a la vida y tú tienes otros
planes tal vez es otra tu voluntad si es
que está bien lo acepto vámonos y tire
la toalla junto a mí había una enfermera
a la búsqueda y le dije cómo te llamas y
ya me dice daiana le dije mira daiana no
voy a salir de esta pero te voy a pedir
dos favores por favor busca mi esposa
habla con ella se llama alejandra dile
que me perdone que le voy a fallar que
la voy a dejar sola con tres niños que
es lo mejor que me pasa en mi vida que
la amo pero que es una gran mujer y que
tiene que salir adelante y que mi última
voluntad es que sea feliz si se quiere
volver a casar el apoyo totalmente pero
que haga feliz a esos chamacos que salga
adelante y por favor segundo favor
daiana busca a mi hijo diego es el
grande tiene ocho años por favor dile
que me perdone papá no va a estar aquí
su héroe se va perdone que le falle pero
dile que lo último que pidió papá es que
él tenía que ser feliz que va a ser un
aumento muy difícil que va a ser una
etapa muy complicada pero que tiene que
salir adelante y tiene que ser feliz y
hacer felices a sus hermanos pequeños ya
mamá por favor díselo daiana y dayana me
dice no no no daiana me toma con su mano
izquierda mis manos con su mano derecha
la pone sobre mi frente me mira a los
ojos con una mirada impresionante de
amor y me dice no no te me vas a quedar
vamos a salir de esta juntos vamos tú
puedes y de una forma inexplicable deje
de temblar en ese momento el doctor pudo
hacer su procedimiento removieron el
coágulo bueno dos coágulos que vi en mi
corazón y sentí como la sangre y la vida
regresaba a mi cuerpo para los que nos
entraron si las sobreviví
yo sé que parece el programa del
discovery chanel si las sobreviví estoy
aquí gracias a una cadena de milagros
por un lado estoy aquí gracias a una
reacción espectacular de mi esposa tomó
las decisiones adecuadas en ese momento
tuve la frialdad para actuar estoy aquí
y gracias a mi querido amigo el doctor
jan y no daneri todos sus años de
experiencia todo su estudio los puso en
práctica en ese momento pero también
estoy aquí gracias a la humanidad de
daiana a veces subestimamos el impacto
que podemos tener en otros seres humanos
hemos caído demasiado en la tecnología y
se nos está olvidando esa conexión que
podemos tener con otros seres humanos es
momento que empecemos a medir el éxito
empresarial no solamente por variables
económicas sino que cambiemos nuestra
definición de éxito que incluyamos en
esa definición el impacto que tenemos en
la vida de otros seres humanos el
impacto que podemos tener en la
comunidad nunca subestimen el impacto
que pueden tener en otros seres humanos
no les tienen que cambiar la vida
es el día actitudes pequeñas ser
generoso ser compasivo ser paciente así
es como se cambian las cosas bueno mis
estimados hable de tres pasos rápidos
para ver muy rápidos perdón que haya
hablado tan rápido para generar ideas
para generar proyectos que impacten
verdaderamente la vida de otras personas
pero vamos a ver cómo es el proceso de
generar esas ideas no va a ser fácil
cuando estés pensando y digas bueno
quiero generar una idea transformar la
vida de otras personas te voy a decir
cómo empieza y empieza en una total
oscuridad te vas a sentir perdido en ese
momento no vas a saber hacia dónde
actuar cuando te sientas en la total
oscuridad tienes que confiar en tu
estilo tal vez en tu estilo personal
está la clave para ayudar a otras
personas tal vez tu forma de ser es la
clave te garantizo que pensándolo se te
va a ocurrir una idea un primer bosquejo
para transformar la vida otras personas
al principio esa idea va a parecer tonta
no va a tomar forma no va a salir como
la esperabas nadie te va a entender la
versión 1.0 siempre apesta así es el
mundo de las ideas asís del mundo de los
prototipos pero tranquilo hay que ser
constante que ser disciplinado hay que
saber escuchar a otras personas hay que
escuchar nuevos puntos de vista y seguir
trabajando en esa idea y te garantizo
que alguien te va a dar una nueva
perspectiva una nueva forma de pensar y
te va a llegar finalmente esa idea que
te traiga una nueva inspiración y que
traiga la luz a tu camino pero aquí una
lección importante mis estimados
sobrevaloramos las ideas y algo aprendía
en la industria de videojuegos es que
las ideas no valen nada lo que le da
valor a una idea no es la idea en sí
misma o quien la dice lo que le da valor
a una idea es la cantidad de gente que
cree en ella la cantidad de vidas que
transforma cómo se contagia esa idea
tienen todos ustedes por ahí un globo
que representa todas las ideas que van a
ver en este test de nada sirven si no le
ponen su propio aliento y su propia luz
porfa
tomen ese globo pónganle su propio
aliento y ayúdenme con su celular
pónganle su propia luz quieres
transformar la vida de otras personas
quieres impactar en la vida de otras
personas número uno descubre cuáles son
tus fortalezas descubre que te apasiona
descubre cuál es tu luz e irradia la
quieres ayudar a otras personas
ayúdalos a descubrir su luz ayúdalos a
descubrir sus fortalezas
déjalos pensar ayúdanos a visualizar una
mejor versión de sí mismos y déjalos que
irradian luz y así es como se
transforman las cosas así es como se
ilumina este lugar queremos cambiar este
país queremos cambiar una sociedad lo
más importante mis estimados es que
trabajemos juntos y que dejemos a la
gente brillar irradiar luz haz que otros
brillen y te garantizo que jamás te va a
faltar luz en tu camino muchas gracias a
todos por estar aquí bueno ésta
[Aplausos]